blac chyna has lawyered up against Rob  Kardashian following their online  blowout China is reportedly taking legal  action against her ex it loves to like  see me get hot and I'm just sick and  tired of him like poo me after Rob went  on a rampage on social media Wednesday  posting a series of nude pics that  appeared to be China accusing her of  cheating using drugs and having their  daughter dream out of spite the 30 year  old reality star may be headed to court  on Friday China's attorney Lisa bloom  tweeted I just gave Rob Kardashian  notice that we'll be in court Monday  seeking restraining orders against him  more to come the day before bloom  weighed in on the sticky situation  writing what Rob Kardashian did to blac  Chyna could be revenge porn and illegal  I personally don't really agree with the  whole thing et has reached out to bloom  for a comment as well as the family  longtime friend and ælis attorney Robert  Shapiro to see if he will represent Rob